hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute haben wir mit samira zusammen
gebacken und zwar gibt es diese kleinen
süßen othello blümchen und zwar ist es
eine blume aus mürbeteig und schoko
heftig da ist eine creme mit drin mit
nutella und innen drinnen noch ein
klecks marmelade und das sorgt natürlich
für die frische in diesem gebäck morath
was sagst du zu ich musste es probieren
sieht richtig hübsch aus ja jetzt auch
durch probieren erst am ende denn ich
zeige euch jetzt zuerst einmal die
zutaten für den teig für den schock um
werkzeug also den 123 teig brauche ich
100 gramm zucker 200 gramm butter 250
gramm mehl und 50 gramm kakaopulver 1 3
etwas meinl extrakt und eine prise salz
zuerst gebe ich jetzt den zucker in eine
rührschüssel gemeinsam mit der butter
und die butter ist noch sehr kalt und
deswegen habe ich so auch in kleine
stückchen geschnitten
jetzt kann ich die zwei zutaten erste
medaille
jetzt kommt dass ein noch mit dazu und
normalerweise gebe ich ja beim absteigen
immer ganz gern nur das eigelb mit rein
aber in diesem fall möchte ich jetzt
dass der teig etwas fester wird und
stabiler wird und nicht so bröselt
deswegen kommt eben das ganze ein mit
rein dann noch eine prise salz und etwas
von den extrakt jetzt werden die zutaten
noch mal miteinander verrührt jetzt gebe
ich noch das kakaopulver mit dazu und
einen teil des mehls haben sich das erst
mal alles gut miteinander verbinden
und das restliche mädel das kenne ich
jetzt noch kurz mit den händen ein
sonderbar relativ zügig gehen denn der
teig soll jetzt nicht warm werden
wenn ihr beim kneten merkt dass hier
noch etwas mehr benötigt weil der teig
einfach noch zu weich ist könnte ruhig
noch ein bisschen mehr meter zu geben
jetzt muss ich den tag erstmal abdecken
und ich mache dann immer ganz gerne ein
bisschen flach da kann ich nämlich in
den kühlschrank geben und für mindestens
eine halbe stunde kühl ist jetzt
abgekühlt und jetzt kann ich ihn dünn
ausrollen
ich mache immer ganz gern auf silikon
matten mit etwas mehl und hat dann zwei
hölzer die sims 3 mm dick und da kann
ich den teig schön gleichmäßig ausrollen
ich habe ich bereits einem muffin form
mit etwas back trance trier 1 gefährdet
und zwar ist eine mini muffin form
jetzt habe ich hier einen blauen
ausstecher und zwar ist er hat so ein
bisschen größer als die mav in form also
das sieht man hier auch ganz gut jetzt
stelle ich damit die blumen aus
dann nimmt man die blumen und dann lege
ich sie mit ich direkt auf einen
förmchen drückst ganz vorsichtig rein
jetzt kann man mit den fingern hier oben
die blütenblätter so ein bisschen nach
außen streichen
die blumen werden jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 160 grad ober unterhitze
etwa zehn minuten gebrochen
die blumen cups sind gebacken und ich
hab's ja auch abkühlen lassen
sie sind jetzt richtig schön fest und
vor allem vorm fest jetzt mache ich da
noch eine füllung und zwar kommt da ein
klecks marmelade mit reihen des oft und
für so ein bisschen als twitter halten
fruchtiger und dann machen wir noch
einen hotel la creme die hat sich dieser
mir so sehr gewünscht und ich zeige mich
davor noch mal kurz die zutaten
wir brauchen dafür 200 g schlagsahne 175
g frischkäse etwa zwei bis drei
esslöffel nutella zwei teelöffel seiner
fahrt und ich habe hier noch eine
marmelade und zwar ist es eine
himbeermarmelade ohne stückchen und fein
püriert nämlich direkt die marmelade und
zwar habe ich hier jetzt darfst du habe
ich hier bereits etwas wasser aufgekocht
darfst du mir helfen willst du die tüte
auf super es geht jetzt in den
gefrierbeutel clubs den wärmen wir die
marmelade damit sie bloß ich hier und
hängt es dafür einfach in papas teekanne
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal die creme zu bereiten und nehmen
dafür die schlagsahne und schlagt sie
mit zwei teelöffeln seiner werkstatt
und jetzt verrühren wir nur teller mit
frischkäse gut gehe
ich sage noch unterheben und da ist die
creme auch schon fertig ja unterheben
mit dem teig sharp machst du
mal probieren
kaffee schmeckt die creme fühle ich
jetzt in einen spritzbeutel und zwar
habe ich da vorne eine große loch hülle
drauf mit 10 mm durchmesser
jetzt schneide ich vorne beim gefrieren
eine kleine spitze ein
und jetzt kommt immer ein klecks
marmelade rein
und jetzt für dich diktieren auf
so zum abschluss kommt jetzt auch die
dekoration drauf und zwar habe ich ihnen
zwei esslöffel nutella in einem
gefrierbeutel auch im wasserbad kurz
erwärmt wahrscheinlich ist eine spitze
in der tk und dann kommt es hier direkt
darüber mit stufe verkosten
ganz kurz kühl stellen
danach die samira gleich probieren wir
stellen sie noch mal eine halbe stunde
im kühlschrank die nutella brötchen sind
jetzt fertig und murat und samira dürft
jetzt probieren ja aber er ist mein
kleiner aus ich finde die szene hat sich
hübsch schlägt die creme einfach raus
welche taktik ist es noch ein bisschen
verbessern können das war hast du kannst
mich ein café rein machen oder zum
kaffee servieren
das kommt dem moratti vermisste hat
immer kaffee aber noch alles mit jeder
kaffee aber mit ich denn das so wirklich
super
den kaffee gibt es nämlich einfach mit
dazu den espresso den kern stets für
dich machen
sehr gut freut mich dass dieser roubaix
ankommen und falls ihr jetzt auch lust
auf diese blümchen bekommen habt dann
geht es meinem blog sallys - blog.de
da stehen noch mal die zutaten ganz
genau und ich glaube nicht reich
wirklich richtigkeit haben als obwohl
die jubilarin 18 nummer der nächsten mal
wieder ins kino wetter nehme ich die
ganze platte jetzt